Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In a previous episode, we talked about a class
of learning algorithms that were endowed with
curiosity.
This new work also showcases a curious AI
that aims to solve Montezuma's revenge which
is a notoriously difficult platform game for
an AI to finish.
The main part of the difficulty arises from
the fact that the AI needs to be able to plan
for longer time periods, and interestingly,
it also needs to learn that short-term rewards
don't necessarily mean long-term success.
Let's have a look at an example - quoting
the authors:
"There are four keys and six doors spread
throughout the level.
Any of the four keys can open any of the six
doors, but are consumed in the process.
To open the final two doors the agent must
therefore forego opening two of the doors
that are easier to find and that would immediately
reward it for opening them."
So what this means is that we have a tricky
situation, because the agent would have to
disregard the fact that it is getting a nice
score from opening the doors, and understand
that these keys can be saved for later.
This is very hard for an AI to resist, and,
again, curiosity comes to the rescue.
Curiosity, at least, this particular definition
of it works in a way that the harder to guess
for the AI what will happen, the more excited
it gets to perform an action.
This drives the agent to finish the game and
explore as much as possible because it is
curious to see what the next level holds.
You see in the animation here that the big
reward spikes show that the AI has found something
new and meaningful, like losing a life, or
narrowly avoiding an adversary.
As you also see, climbing a ladder is a predictable,
boring mechanic that the AI is not very excited
about.
Later, it becomes able to predict the results
even better the second and third time around,
therefore it gets even less excited about
ladders.
This other animation shows how this curious
agent explores adjacent rooms over time.
This work also introduces a technique, which
the authors call random network distillation.
This means that we start out from a completely
randomly initialized, untrained neural network,
and over time, slowly distill it into a trained
one.
This distillation also makes our neural network
immune to the noisy TV problem from our previous
episode, where our curious, unassuming agent
would get stuck in front of a TV that continually
plays new content.
It also takes into consideration the score
reported by the game, and has an internal
motivation to explore as well.
And hold on to your papers, because it can
not only perform well in the game, but this
AI is able to perform better than the average
human.
And again, remember that no ground truth knowledge
is required, it was never demonstrated to
the AI how one should play this game.
Very impressive results indeed, and you see,
the pace of progress in machine learning research
is nothing short of incredible.
Make sure to have a look at the paper in the
video description for more details.
We'd also like to send a big thank you to
Insilico Medicine for supporting this video.
They use AI for research on preventing aging,
believe it or not, and are doing absolutely
amazing work.
Make sure to check them out in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!